the city of Maiduguri during the Islamic
festival of Salah Muslim families
intermingle as groups of blue-clad
civilian paramilitaries stand guard
against possible Boko Haram attacks
something they say the Army has failed
to do the young residents began arming
themselves in 2013 we just sacrifice our
safe so that the peace will reign in
Maiduguri
that is our imagines that is ideology of
every civil entity
today the civilian jtf has around 26,000
members many a school dropouts who serve
little alternative to fighting in the
militia their growth has left residents
worried that my degree is turning
increasingly violent activists I've met
by lorry is one of them locals call him
a peace ambassador the muharram blues
and the more government counters in
inappropriate manner the more you know
you know aggressive our people were
trying to be it's giving it's changing
the culture and mindset of our people
our people are now right becoming
violent by the day and our people have
to fight to survive day in day out every
month he gathers members of the
community to build networks of activists
and to work on education programs one
initiative aims to encourage young
people to return to school and to speak
out against hate speech and he
encourages our community people to
enroll their children to school and he
always bring exercise books for children
and also help especially he helps me
with cash returns to pay my children's
school fees
Maira giri's official motto is home of
peace but peace disappeared when Boko
Haram came says Musa Dada
he hopes that Bull Ori will push harder
to improve the situation however many
youngsters admire the civilian Joint
Task Force now al yousuf a research at
the university of Maiduguri positive
resistance culture of violence villain
j'tia what they are doing really attract
a young ones to join them and also to be
like them they are supposed to be in the
school and the primary school and the
scandals about not fighting Boko Haram
Larabar Muhammed is checking worshipers
for weapons she joined the militia when
she was 17 after Boko Haram had killed
her husband and father she prides
herself on being braver than her male
crow fighters nevertheless she still
dreams of becoming a doctor we are
hopeful that one day we will study and
get good jobs our government just
promised as that but for now the
civilian ktf does not expect to defeat
Boko Haram anytime soon they continue to
recruit new members steadily
militarizing Maiduguri and so grows the
need to offer its youth an alternative
future perhaps only then can the city
reclaim its place as home of peace to
discuss the security situation in the
region we sat down with the deputy
chairman of the African Union Kwesi
Forte we asked why it is so difficult to
overcome Boko Haram in the Chad basin
it is not for want of trying and Salina
for want of willingness the situation we
found determines everything I
institutions when they are were
developed assists you know but at other
times you know in in Lake Chad region
this connection of Boko Haram for
instance you know like chart used to be
the water body which give life and
employment and could live in all the
countries the neighborhood surrounding
it knowledge child is drying up in the
drive of the chart the consequential
damage to a primer to livelihood to life
in general leads to depression lack of
every hood the young people inability to
go to school they become easy targets
for fanatics and extremists and the I
slowly introduced to ants and then we
come to a long con travel I think that
is what mail happening in the election
region and is relationship Boko Haram